[Musique]
les essentiels du Sénat
quelle perspective pour le cinéma en
France
depuis 2010 la fréquentation des salles
de cinéma tandem a augmenté en 2019 elle
a même atteint 213 millions de
spectateurs le meilleur total depuis
1966 mais la crise pandémique s'est
brutalement imposée l'année 2022 avec
une baisse de près de 30% par rapport à
2019 a été loin de lever toutes les
inquiétudes face aux nouvelles
technologies le cinéma n'a jamais paru
si questionné et menacé dans ce contexte
la commission de la culture a confié à
Céline boulet espéronier Sonia de la
pauvreté et Jérémy Baki une mission
d'information visant à envisager les
perspectives de la filière
cinématographique
la mission d'information a permis
d'identifier les différents métiers du
cinéma de cerner les visions du secteur
et ses perspectives de se pencher sur
les modes de financement du cinéma et
sur la fréquentation des salles mais
aussi de saisir l'intérêt de cette
industrie culturelle pour les
territoires le succès du cinéma en
France s'explique par une volonté
politique portée sur le long terme par
un ensemble institutionnel et
professionnel le CNC Centre national du
cinéma et de l'image animée soutient les
projets accompagnent les filières et
finances les créateurs la filière repose
en outre sur un système d'obligation
d'investissement des diffuseurs des
chaînes et des plateformes
par ailleurs la chronologie des médias
permet la sauvegarde de l'exploitation
en salle des films aussi la France
dispose d'un solide écosystème de
formation et d'une tradition de
savoir-faire
néanmoins l'usage des plateformes de
streaming à distendu le lien entre film
et sale dans le même temps si la France
a accru sa production de films la
fréquentation n'a pas suivi la
production ce qui a eu pour effet de
fragiliser l'ensemble des films français
pour permettre à notre cinéma et à nos
salles de s'adapter et de poursuivre
leur double vocation artistique et
populaire la mission a formulé 14
recommandations opérationnelles
regroupées en cinq axes
elle estime essentielle d'adapter les
mécanismes de soutien du CNC afin de
privilégier des productions mieux
financées et distribuées
parallèlement elle préconise de
renforcer les mécanismes de distribution
et de diffusion et de faciliter la vie
des exploitants elle encourage à
promouvoir une meilleure diffusion et
une meilleure connaissance des films sur
le territoire
la mission recommande aussi de mieux
associer le cinéma aux politiques
publiques notamment en proposant de
conditionner les aides du CNC au respect
d'obligation environnementale lors des
tournages ainsi qu'au respect des règles
de rémunération minimale des acteurs
enfin elle suggère de renforcer les
acteurs économiques français dans la
chronologie des médias les rapporteurs
envisagent le dépôt prochain d'une
proposition de loi pour mettre en
application les préconisations qui
nécessitent des modifications
législatives
pour en savoir plus consultez le site
Internet du Sénat
[Musique]